We've spent a long time
building a content provider.
But, we are only using
it just enough for
us to test that we got
the content provider working.
When we query the database,
here's how these classes are used.
Our UI, first, builds a URI,
using the weathercontract.
The UI then uses this UI to call
a method in the Content Resolver.
Which ultimately forwards
the request to our WeatherProvider.
Our WeatherProvider
uses Weather DB Helper
to get an instance of SQLite Database.
Creating, or updating the tables
of our database is necessary.
We then pass the SQL query
to the SQLiteDatabase class,
which sends our query off
to our SQLite database.
Cursor Loader takes the URI, and
calls the Content Resolver on our
behalf, inside of an AsyncTask.
Ultimately, the cursor gets
returned to the Android UI,
and it will be used by a cursor adapter,
to populate the list view,
in Sunshine from our database cursor.
Similar to the way our array adapter
populated the list view from an array.
For our next task, we are going
to replace the array adapter,
we have currently in forecast fragment,
with a cursor adapter.
We'll eventually connect it to our
database using a cursor loader.